Maybe it's a mom putting her baby's life at
risk or a dad stopping his son from pursuing
his dreams.
Or maybe the parents are just straight-up
homicidal.
Whether they're letting loose with emotional
abuse or trying to give their kids a permanent
timeout, these are the worst parents in movie
history.
Marvel dads are the worst.
They lie to their kids, disappoint them, and
in some instances, try to murder them.
And they don't get any worse than Thanos,
the Mad Titan with terrible parenting skills.
He's a purple warlord who wants to annihilate
half the universe, but he also fancies himself
a father figure.
When he's not murdering entire planets full
of people, he's busy adopting kids to join
his little death cult.
And by "adopting," we mean killing their parents
and kidnapping them.
"Unh-uh.
Concentrate."
Naturally, life with Thanos can be kind of
traumatizing, as he often forces his kids
to fight each other in bloody, brutal duels.
He particularly enjoys torturing his daughter
Nebula, cutting off her body parts and replacing
them with hunks of metal.
He may have fond feelings for Gamora but at
the end of the day, he throws her off a cliff
so he can get his hands on a shiny stone.
When your rock collection is more important
than your own kids, it means you probably
weren't cut out for this whole adoption thing.
Played to perfection by Allison Janney in
the biopic I, Tonya, LaVona Golden is a chain-smoking,
hard-drinking, foul-mouthed devil woman.
As the mother of ice skater Tonya Harding,
she does all sorts of horrible things to push
her little girl to glory.
She nags her from the sidelines, violently
beats her, and forces her to skate so long
that she pees in the rink.
Even when Tonya grows up, LaVona keeps going
with the put-downs.
Every look she shoots her daughter is dripping
with anger and disdain.
She won't even tell her daughter that she
loves her, probably because she doesn't love
anything except her cigarettes.
Later on, she justifies her awful behavior
by saying:
"I made you a champion, knowing you'd hate
me for it.
That's a sacrifice a mother makes."
But really, Golden just drives her daughter
towards a life of abuse and scandal.
At first glance, Ego the Living Planet seems
like the perfect dad.
He saves his long-lost son, Peter Quill, from
an army of bad guys.
He invites him to live in a gorgeous paradise.
And he even looks like Kurt Russell.
Sure, he hasn't been a part of Peter's life
for decades, but now they're reunited and
ready for an overdue game of catch.
Alas, Ego is a godlike being who wants to
spread his seed across the universe, in more
ways than one.
His plan involves planting extraterrestrial
flowers that will eventually transform entire
planets into extensions of his consciousness.
"...until everything is me."
But he needs help carrying out his plan in
the form of another demigod with similar powers.
So he goes around the universe, impregnating
basically every being he comes across.
When his kids are all grown, he brings them
to his homeworld to see if they inherited
any of his Celestial abilities.
If they haven't, he kills them and leaves
their remains in a cave full of bones.
There are bad dads, and then there are straight-up
evil dads.
Jack Torrance falls in the latter category.
Played by Jack Nicholson in The Shining, Torrance
is a writer and a caretaker at the mountainside
Overlook Hotel.
He starts off a little psycho and just gets
more unhinged as the film goes on.
"Then I'll huff and I'll puff and I'll blow
your house in."
That psychosis isn't good for Jack's son Danny,
who possesses a psychic ability called "the
shining," that allows him to see all the evil
spirits lurking in the Overlook.
But despite his powers, he can't stop his
dad from going completely insane, grabbing
an axe, and calling him over for some bloody
father-son bonding time.
Jack chases little Danny all over the hotel
and out into the snowy hedge maze, where the
kid manages to outsmart and escape his dastardly
old dad.
And in Jack's final moments, he learns that
trying to kill his kid does not make him a
cool parent.
Well actually, it kind of does.
Life can be hard when you're an introverted
teenager who's relentlessly bullied while
developing scary psychic powers.
A girl like that really needs a mom to care
for her and guide her through those difficult
times.
Unfortunately for Carrie White, her mother
is an absolute nut job who'd rather stab her
daughter with a butcher's knife than help
her figure out high school.
Played by Piper Laurie, Margaret White is
a psycho who wants to keep Carrie as isolated
from the world as possible.
When Carrie has her first period, Margaret
locks her in a closet and forces her to pray
for forgiveness for her wicked ways.
When she goes off to prom, Margaret does everything
she can to keep Carrie at home, telling her
all her classmates will just laugh at her.
It all culminates in a candle-lit showdown
when Margaret looks a little too happy while
trying to stab her daughter to death.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.